So this is just magical.
Yesterday, as we already discussed,
Donald Trump did what might be his last ever rally
as president and he did it in Dalton, Georgia.
And Fox News Channel was on the ground there. And
reporter Griff Jenkins was interviewing people
and he starts interviewing some guy with a
huge red stop the steel hat who apparently had
been camping out in a sleeping bag awaiting last
night's rally. And as this is going on, there's a
guy in a magazine hat in the background flashing
this new white power hand signal with his hand.
And I'll explain more about that in a moment.
And although it takes about 12 seconds too long,
maybe 14 seconds, eventually Fox News
makes the decision to just cut the video
and they cut to a shot of the White House in which
nothing is going on. And I'll explain to you after
we look at the clip how we know that this was
definitely an abrupt decision made live. They
weren't purposely saying, hey, at this point,
we planned to show you what was going on at the
White House. It was a decision made on the fly
to get the white power symbol off the screen.
Take a look and then we'll discuss in the
elections tomorrow. Do you care about that?
Are you worried about that? Absolutely. I think
everybody in the nation should care about it. It's
a federal issue in a way who becomes senators.
It's going to have a very big impact on the
Senate. I support Senators Perdue and Loffler.
I hope that they are elected. And, you know,
if somebody from California can come out here and
camp out in zero degree weather in a sleeping bag
on the asphalt, maybe a few more voters from
Georgia will find the time to get to the polls
quickly. Blake, do you believe, since you're
worried about the stuff, the steal in election
shenanigans, are you worried about the integrity
of the election tomorrow for Leffler and Perdue?
Yeah, absolutely. I'm worried about it. And I just
hope that the correct actions have been taken to
make sure that this time around the ballot custody
is safeguarded and there aren't, you know, extra.
So after about 14 seconds of that white power
sign being held up, they switch to a shot of
the White House. Now, we can tell this was
a sort of emergency measure, an abrupt,
evasive maneuver, because no one nothing is
happening at the White House in the shot.
Number two, they keep the White House video up too
long to make any visual sense. And number three,
it was on purpose when news networks
switched to a shot of the White House.
Either the voiceover or a lower third will tell
you why. We are looking at the White House like,
for example, they switch to a shot of the White
House and they would say at the bottom, awaiting
Trump departure from White House or something
along those lines. So clearly, this was like an
abrupt attempt to cover the white power and signal
that was taking place during the interview. Now,
hilariously, the 12 or 14 seconds it took to put
the shot, to pull the shot off of the screen,
I would love to know what the conversation was
in the control room. Oh, no white power sign.
Do we cut it? No, no, no. That's too abrupt. Let's
just wait and hope the guy takes it down. Oh, no,
he's keeping it up. OK, let's cut it. Yeah, but
what do we cut to? I don't know. Maybe the White
House. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Cut to the White House
real quick. Now, just to do this justice and make
it informative, you might be saying white power
symbol. The OK hand sign. Ever since I was a kid,
that didn't mean white power. How does it now
mean? White power and context is key here. We
have to be able to as as intelligent Homo sapiens,
apply an understanding of context. In most
situations, the OK hand sign is perfectly fine and
it would be obvious to everybody that it means OK,
not white power. The idea of the hand sign is
that it creates a W and a P and we're putting
up a drawing of that on the screen. And this dates
back to a twenty seventeen hoax from the Internet
where it was falsely promoted as a symbol of hate.
So understand and a lot of people, if you don't
mention this, they get mad. The origins were for
an online enclave to pretend that this is a symbol
of hate, meaning white power, and that it's not in
reality. But then by twenty nineteen, it actually
lost some of the satire. And there are people who
now seriously use it as a symbol of hate. And the
point is we shouldn't jump to conclusions. We have
to analyze each situation here. We have someone
who's deliberately standing in the
background of a shot at a political rally
holding the sign up while wearing Trump gear.
Context tells us he's not telling us everything is
OK and the weather is great. All right. So whether
in this case, it's a satirical white power signal
or a real white power signal, clearly this guy
is not saying great weather, guys. That's what
I'm communicating. And even Fox News recognized it
eventually. I mean, it took them 12 or 14 seconds
and they cut away. What an
amazing time we live in as an.